starve myself i'm about to say i'm about
to say it's unfair he's lived poor
before yeah
that's
nothing for him dude we lived in a he
just went back to motor homes
mobile home park mobile home park yeah
we were poor when we came because my
parents are immigrants well i'm an
immigrant so they had to learn how to
get a job not even on english
[Music]
i always say like what does ass and
titties have to do with food and
beverage because it makes them talk it
makes the lonely people at the bar talk
to the bartender more and buy more
drinks that's right and it isn't mike
because that first sentence eric said
was a great place to start welcome to
cats after dark
are you comfortable
here we go
it makes a ton of sense
haters hate here i am
oh no uh we have we'll get to some
listener comments it's a section we do
sometime we only get love on this show
they'll love you eric
thanks for joining with us
um our i think we've had some
up-and-coming comedians i'm sure you
know the name like uh matt lockwood
uh and and guys like that but i think
you're a first touring headliner oh sure
uh so i'm out here slump go you
dominated with uh
repping chin's like like the late late
late late show yeah who came on after
uh seth
whatever his name in i don't think
anybody it was like yeah somebody used
to have that they would be like it's
like the paid programming yeah yeah this
is right before they played a national
anthem
yeah i pay brendan to put this on this
is a pay-per-view
it's like cable access
but uh yeah thanks for joining um you
got shows coming up uh yeah when is this
coming now uh friday oh well yeah yeah
i'm gonna be in la jolla
and then i'm gonna after that the
milwaukee improv then i'm doing the
skank fest and then i'm gonna be at the
colusa casino so all right enough of
that oh yeah what is this all about and
also
honestly we're still it's uh episode 28
we're still trying to find our footing
what we do here oh so okay i get it but
today
but today we actually have a lot of
stuff to talk about i'm 199 episodes in
of riffing with griffin and i still
don't know what i'm saying
constant evolution is important in
podcasts i guess you can't rest on your
laurels
our first episode of 120 000 views or
something i know i got so excited i was
like [ __ ] those guys
we got a show though
we talked about it though we were like
oh there's going to be a yeah
there's always the curiosity yeah
they're like oh
what that show is it was decent at the
beginning and then chappelle quit that
cat quit
but they're coming back once in a while
yeah yeah remember people
i don't believe yeah but we won't tell
you so you have to tune in to every show
yeah it's gonna be a surprise it's like
the after stern uh
that was that was kind of my concept
when i started it but then there's not
enough that goes on like
i don't know the schedule doesn't work
we don't record right after the episode
that's gonna go out so it's like i don't
know well you should yeah that's the
consistency you need and we don't give
you like one wasn't it great when they
said this and what that's what you're
supposed to be supposed to be about yeah
and uh we'll we'll we're working out we
are gonna do a king of the sting
superfan trivia contest uh we got our
final eight and that starts next week so
that's that's related back and uh i'm
going to try to beg the guys that we can
fly the winner out here uh
but uh if not i've already promised to
spend my own money on spirit for them
you gotta catch him in the moment
he's he's like this
yeah i just catch him in the moment we
should fly this guy don't you think you
know what i mean he asked while he was
walking out and you're just like yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah they make him do it
theo was like theo's the same that's
what i'm saying why do you think this
guy's here and every day is like what
how did this
[Laughter]
i mean
he actually had an accomplishment though
it's like you showed work dropping 300
pounds or whatever
so i feel like he didn't just ask he's
like oh look i i've got some discipline
but even still though it's like a thing
where you just kind of go okay
you know we joked i think all of us here
got our jobs essentially just by asking
except george you actually had a job
listing submitted a resume we went up to
well i asked kyle basically oh yeah yeah
uh so he did ask but just one more yeah
yeah but uh but then i have to yeah
today we do have stuff to talk about
chin just got back from a show in ohio
with uh little brows looked almost sold
out uh well it's not gonna be so it's
eleven hundred uh seated or oh you know
oh so it's like they were not gonna
still say it was a good show no so last
year we sold but when you say like it
almost sold out it just sounds sold out
that's something that's cool it sounds
like a backhanded comment no but i mean
seriously who are we you know we just
started doing this together like lesson
what maybe we did two years right
now i mean brows no since the king of
the scene um rap contest oh okay yeah so
me and him just started talking making
music and now we're
the first show we did was like 300 plus
tickets and then this one that we just
did was sold over 500 tickets oh so
we're just starting a boy band again and
i'm in my 40s doing this like if i'm
just starting to do this again like it's
kind of crazy
so thank you ohio all your band members
are jealous you know they're all uh no
they're they're all well there's some
that are successful as hell right now oh
really oh wow
but that no that's the path they chose i
didn't choose to go that path yeah i
gave up for a while could have done i
want to do it yeah
why didn't doing that was this before
the game after the game
it just was like during the game
that sounds a little busy they actually
kicked you out because of the game
they're like
secretly what if you found that out
secretly they were like well we heard
about your gang affiliation never been
in the gang
[Laughter]
i was friends with gang members drag
racing with backstreet boys playing yeah
then i knew you had that much everybody
i knew something was wrong i'm like what
am i doing
here backstreet racing
to do the song with him but it just
didn't work out oh the first the first
one over at the in l.a the jupiter which
is a legendary location like dude it
would have been amazing if you were
there
yeah it would have been great but yeah
yeah you play that without sound
that looks dope though that's crazy yeah
over 500 tickets is a [ __ ]
question that's pretty insane so and
that's great because these are actually
all
king and sting fans too obviously huh a
lot of them yeah a lot of them were but
then
i think that's his hometown that's
austin's hometown yeah that yeah i mean
i mean i mean both i mean it's like yeah
he built you know i mean dude of course
the the shows are what the reason why
people even know who we are yeah yeah
yeah but you had austin awake he was
also in a wake-up he's a huge youtube
guy like yeah he's got nothing following
him yeah well i mean this is why i'm
saying like it would be great to do like
a comedy music tour of
gosh this would be yeah know with all
that that would be so fantastic have you
ever done the goddamn comedy jam yeah
yeah i'm sure you just crushed that yeah
yeah i do i love doing that i just did
it i had some couple of things on my
instagram from that
uh do you know what is that show uh it's
um
you i can't remember the guy's name
uh josh adams
joshua meyer you do a little bit of
stand up based about whatever song
you're gonna do and then you sing a song
oh that's cool
he gets like any
touring headline comic that you've done
like they've like bill bird bill does a
lot of time mark mark maron's actually a
great musician wow what is this i don't
know this is what you sent me chen did i
yeah i must have sent you the wrong
video then well let's see what he said
yeah let's see what it is
huh okay
what the hell
let me reset you
so did you ever get your guitar in your
bag i did hey
um it must be a hassle to have to like
carry on your guitar dude it sucks yeah
it really does because you never can put
it in any place
you're also just flying cheap so the
shuttles you know sometimes you just
shuttle to get to the rental car
then having the guitar there and that
sucks wait do you bring the guitar on is
it like carry on or
no no so i check my guitar in okay which
is already a pain
but then when you finally get to the
destination
then you have to like go you know i had
to rent a car this time oh so you don't
carry it on so no no carry it on they
have that yeah but definitely no i don't
want to be that person that takes up
that much room well usually they find
some closet to put it in it's like i
don't even get sometimes i don't even
get like there are certain airline ones
that nothing can fit in there
what is this just space they're like
don't angle your bag this way or else it
won't close
uh but uh
so we also speaking we talked about
george's weight loss we had some i guess
we had net weight loss together
uh we did a competition
uh who could lose more weight in five
weeks we weighed in we were both 199
pounds uh we weighed in this morning
chin you were
i think it was 208 209 he gained nine
pounds
five weeks
i lost 28. can you imagine this 20
pounds in five weeks that's crazy yeah i
starve myself about to say i'm about to
say it's unfair he's lived poor before
yeah
nothing for him dude we lived in a went
back to motorhome uh not a mobile home
mobile home park mobile home park yeah
we were poor when we came because my
parents are immigrants well i'm an
immigrant
so they had to learn how to get a job
not even knowing english it's nothing
like trailer trash
see we still nobody knows
hey man it's actually kind of nice yeah
i like i had been thinking about that
since like i have disposable income like
now
i'm sure like a lot of us just ordering
post mates like 30 on a sandwich and i
was thinking about when i was like
either in my car or the first 450 living
room i rented out like
when i got like a good meal it was
[ __ ] really exciting i was splurging
but then you get to a point where buying
the food
you could always buy like bad food and i
was like i do want to go back to that
when i could like i don't know you just
you enjoyed stuff so much better when i
finally went and got a chipotle burrito
instead of just like oh now i have that
every day so that was my mindset when i
was like just go back to when i was poor
i really did that yeah that's what i'm
saying it worked i get it
um but since you lost
thank you
you paid up on your bet and you brought
hundred dollars and hundred dollar bills
too but uh because i am magnanimous i'm
going to give you a chance to win your
money back
and we're gonna do six competitions
and each one will be worth a hundred
dollars but there will also be a fan who
gets a chance and i forgot we actually
do have to zoom someone in so if you can
plug in all that stuff uh but uh
the fan will have a chance to win
their money by eric playing for them
and we're gonna have six competitions
they are
target practice
we will shoot a cup off of christian's
head okay i love it there's multiple
shots or just one well one one clip and
most times two knock off the uh yeah but
you have to oh okay okay you get that
one test shot
what one full clip um you get one you
can put it you want to hit him he has to
keep putting the cup on his head yeah
yeah yeah
uh so that one's not time then we have
bop it
game of dexterity quickness
most on bob you ever seen a bop it no
you've never heard about it they used to
be black back in the day this is like a
cheap newer bop it so
there's no very cheap apparently oh no
my pop it's dead
oh
and it goes faster it goes press and if
you press the wrong one then you pull it
yeah
bop it twist it and pull it look at
eric's face i've never heard of bop it
bobby i don't think he likes him
but what happened to monopoly
i didn't go seek you know or operation
[Music]
that is one of our six games that's
three
then we have a water chugging
competition which i think is gonna be
it's not that hard it lasts 30 seconds
you put a straw in you press the button
when it overflows then that's your time
the longest to go without it overflowing
okay wins
for
um
damn it i should have wrote these down i
had uh trivia trivia oh trivia we've got
six trivial pursuit questions
and
holding your breath
did we stick with holding your breath i
thought we thought we found it i
couldn't think of a sixth one
where we were sticking with holding your
butt how about armor oh you said you had
to donate arm wrestling uh holding your
breath that's such a five-year-old i
know i mean i plus a big bunch of shame
yeah i'm sure people can cheat unless
someone's like standing right next to us
and hearing us not breathe i mean they
started like the nose and then
yeah but i could do that and still
breathe
how about you don't cheat
just be honest
someone else has to hold yourself this
is how the start of nick's gambling
addiction
for sure he's like can you hold your
breath i can hold mine for 30. he's like
i'll bet you like six cookies and your
breakfast actually it was when i was
poor and i went to private school and we
started playing poker tournaments for
way too much money and i would just
leave with like three hundred dollars at
a time from all these rich kids money i
was like i was about to say you
definitely
yeah there's this
i was like he's sick he's like matt
damon from rounders over yeah
literally i got so obsessed with it i i
hadn't seen it at the point but in
rounders in the first scene he like goes
to his drawer and he opens up a book
it's super system by doyle brunson and
that's where he keeps his money right in
the hollowed-out book i had bought that
book when i was 14.
super system by doyle brunson he won the
first
and second world series of porker in
1977 and 19.
that's a whole different that's a whole
different competition
that's since friday night
these days yeah because he would look
like one of those guys that's like you
know whatever he puts my glasses on
were you a fan of johnny chan uh yeah
johnny uh johnny chan was johnny tran or
johnny chan chan yeah
uh so before we get to the competitions
we'll uh we'll check out some listener
comments about
and you can read these he'll bring them
up on screen
don't don't give them a pre-read just
read it and we'll react and okay
usually pretty nice people really
digging what we're doing here at cats
after dark all right
cats add
coffee
so the first one we got cats after dark
love the chemistry guys
there we go
what chin looking buff that trt is
paying off
more business
with four likes
that's all i need man that's all i need
that's after direct record right there
that's when you know the fly hold on
podcast blowing up come on
four
this nick guy is such an overconfident
pain-faced douchebag okay
is there more to it accurate
love the energy of christian
he's like a hyped up puppy just excited
for the world at his paws
love this crew keep it up gently gotta
love the love yeah
first off i'm an ugly mf so no hate but
does nick have a pinch of the downs just
the pinch just the pinch
yeah what would that be just a a touch
of downs yeah but a pinch is even less
right yeah which would be like what's
less like precuts like a pinch no
because it's like let's say you have a
thing of salt and you would take a
little bit of salt and just put it in i
got a salt mayonnaise like in the pasta
water yeah yeah yeah
yeah so then like you know it's there
but you're like what is that yeah that's
just a little
hint of downs okay autism is hot right
now i'm [ __ ] nick has the weirdest
looking teeth
you know what i'm a 100 on that one
little sharp looking chiclet teeth
and they're oddly spaced you know what
i'm saying
my teeth are did you have braces when
you were a kid i should have uh
but no i i didn't and
we were poor so like braces were a thing
but my grandma was like oh you can get
braces but i was like oh
you're so short-sighted i was like i
don't want to have braces from middle
school you know and then it's like two
years later you're like oh i wish i
would have them off now but it does look
like you had braces
and like your mom didn't finish the
payments and they ripped them off here's
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
yeah you know it's bad when the braces
get repossessed
very astute eric though cause what
happened was
i when we were in eighth grade we were
dunking on a nine foot basketball hoop
off a skateboard ramp and i caught my
tooth on the net oh and it ripped it out
completely the root and everything oh
jesus christ and it was actually at a
kids it was funny story it was a at a
kid's uh house who his mom was a dental
hygienist and we found the tooth and he
told his mom he's like put it in milk
put it in milk the calcium keeps it
alive she's like no he's like i read it
in your waiting room so we put it in
milk we took it to the dentist and they
put it back in and they did a root canal
and i had that for like six years
but then it like started to go up and
once you have root canal they like turn
black so then they put a bridge in
first they were going to do a cap but
then
it had worn so much you need to do a
bone graft and then it starts to get
expensive so then there's a bridge and
so these three are like perfect well not
perfect but they're my best to the bunch
that's what i'm saying this is my half
that's my part
your mouth does look like a mosh pit
yeah you know what you're saying
and like a couple of guys were like
my buddy and the other three on the
other side i'm just kind of like the
other three are just like dude those
guys are
my buddy jordan hanson
wait a minute we're not done clowning
you you can't do this
it makes me endearing i get it i have
simpsons
teeth that's the turf that's the proper
term they're round and they're spaced
apart
can you google simpson's teeth your
teeth made it on theo's mural and behind
those old podcasts but yeah always nice
to check in with the fans and see what
they're thinking about the show yeah
that's literal
oh yeah
yeah he yeah you have homer teeth for
sure
homer's got nice teeth
there's some of them that have like
rounded homer is nice
[Laughter]
well that's you after you you got caught
on the basket yeah yeah what one day
before i'm
38 i want to medical tourism get like
caps
like some place well we should just
start like a patreon for that or
something or like yeah george your skin
removal has to be put on hold yeah yeah
that's true
is that started i mean okay so during
the uh the companion with birds got some
k he was here bert offered to pay for a
third of it and then brendan offered to
match him so i have two thirds of it
right now and i told you i'll give you
i'm putting in a ground
i'm putting any ground so what's that
so we're getting a little collection
yeah i'll be there and to be like
come on man you have the most money out
of my point
this is this is a set up now
welcome to cats after the
setup it's just a shakedown picture it's
a shame it's a fancy shakedown they're
not even really you're not even really
going to air this it's just all about me
on tape being like i will give this
amount for
i might throw in something okay and i
don't know how you're doing on your
organs but george here needs a kidney
[Laughter]
i'm gonna have no teeth and he's gonna
i wouldn't mind taking your car
no okay maybe we should do do we start a
skin removal cats after dark gofundme
we'll only promote it in the description
of our shows
uh because like gofundme can get out of
control you post i think you should make
like a little video you should make a
video just being like hey guys i
appreciate all the work i've done up to
this point i just have one more thing to
go it's just you know i've worked on my
health now it's about the cosmetics too
and i need your help and i think people
would appreciate that play this our
mcfarland music in the background
following your journey and you're
inspiring to people you're nice that's
the biggest thing you're inspiring
people yeah you're really inspiring to
people so there's like another step
there's also some downsides to like all
the stuff so you want to it's also you
know helps people to be like all right
yeah
you know
all right let's have chin try to win his
money back what are we playing nothing
are we still doing are they done they're
done okay they get the weirdest teeth uh
is there was there another one uh maybe
one called me a pedal or something i
don't know we're good i think that was
last time
oh yeah yeah uh six that one sticks out
uh yeah once that kind of stuff starts
then people know
well
all right
now it's time
what's going on guys there we go what's
up bro
how are you man
chilling how are you guys doing oh how
are you guys doing how you doing bro
i'm doing well
very well
well that's so awesome
we uh we just said
first come first serve put out the uh
the google voice text number for king
and the sting and i'm so happy it was
you you get a chance to win six hundred
dollars oh snap
watching last week and as you guys were
calling their names i'm like keep
calling them and then they when they
messed up it was so hard for the guys
last week on the names
yeah yeah this is uh this is a little
bit different uh it's gonna be in studio
games and eric is gonna be the one
playing versus you
uh versus versus me and shin and this is
all a chance chin got dominated in our
weight loss competition i won by 37
pounds
uh so yes you have an eighth saturday
what's that oh yeah you have an eighth
and saturday man's an instagram follower
yes i i have not i had a burger this
morning there was some place in cal in
in calabasas and it was open at 8 30.
and you said smash burger but it's not
it said it was smash burger so i was
like what kind of smash burger place is
over at 8 30 and then it came and it was
just like a burger i feel like it was
one of those ghost kitchens people just
do you know oh i love that that they do
that
it's just it's pretty cool yeah
there's one in west l.a man where
there's like it's like nine restaurants
i got food one time i said i'm gonna go
pick up
i'm gonna go i mark to pick up the food
so i get there and i'm like where's the
yeah you know whatever restaurant
they're like oh that's us
and then there were six other people
there one guy was like is this the
cookie place
you know the other guy is this the pizza
oh is this it's all those places i'm
like yeah we're all those places they
have to do that because people are
stupid
people are stupid
people in their minds they're like well
i want to go to a just a chicken place
yeah they should get a sign like cookie
place chicken place
they're doing pizza they don't do the
chicken that's the idea so they just go
we'll just tell them we only do pizza
yeah
it's fair logic it's work uh
remind me of your name again
sir there eric eric and eric oh another
eric that's perfect yeah we got here
dude you're healing well man yeah dude
oh yeah
uh you played a good game yesterday call
of duty
what an awesome guy this is my call of
duty all right i love it i love you guys
when you're on there and twitch you have
to were you looking on youtube
youtube oh yeah yeah i went live on
youtube yesterday for the first time for
the first time yeah you don't usually do
that yeah because apparently i don't
know i think they changed the partner
agreement with twitch because they
lowered the money so i think now it's
not exclusive anymore so like i could
gain money but you can't stream at the
same time that sucks dude yeah but you
could like you know
bounce around you bounce around mm-hmm
it's in
suck like all of a sudden those
platforms they're like we're giving away
too much money and they'll just like uh
the youtube ad apocalypse or whatever a
couple years ago i was was not really
big on youtube but like creators went
from like 10 000 a month to a thousand
dollars a month overnight just crush
people uh but
so we've got six games eric
each game is worth a hundred dollars if
eric wins you get the hundred dollars
if chin wins
he keeps the hundred dollars and if i
win i get my hundred dollars back or no
chin gets a hundred dollars back i keep
the hundred dollars that i have
rightfully won
we'll start with bop it may will you
hand this to eric yeah
i cannot wait
eric has never heard have you heard of
bop it eric no i haven't the other
yeah
you're eric had never so
high score that's that's kind of why
when you press the button it was it was
wrong it's got to be on single player
how's ever going to figure this out uh
here give it back to me
pop it
here here he had the editor edited me
eric is
not i'm
so we just want solo and then you press
pop it to start and then from then on
it'll tell you twist it pull it or bop
it okay
it gets progressively faster
so bop it bop it to start all right how
you hold it is a very interesting
strategy there's there's i don't know if
i've ever seen the knee
try it again
pull the thing i think to wake it up he
said he was going to sleep there you go
he should talk while it's going
he's got to concentrate though yeah
that's
so far this is his first ever game it's
like someone taunting you in the in
baseball he's got to be able to work
through the taunts
the tension is
you off on that one i building you got
that last sorry er
that was good not not looking good for
eric i know sorry wow how's that looking
good the first time he did it i think
hundreds the top scorer i think he got
100 the first time he he what he's
correct
all
i think you just bop it to start
no you twist it oh pull it to turn it on
pop it to start
dude he's adjusting it
oh my god
no you were talking during my thing yeah
don't try and get clogged i couldn't
hear
[Applause]
that's
you
happened
as soon as you said you were talking
during my thing i'm like oh you can't
hear it it needs to be on a freaking
speaker
now you know
blasting uh all right this is this puts
me in a tough spot because i'm a
competitor what was his score yeah they
really want you to have a hundred
dollars there we'll make sure you lose
don't worry no i'm going to win this
thing i'm sorry here
100 congratulations sir hey
thank you very much so what are you
going to do mail it to him i know
uh no i'll then want to him yeah no i
got hundreds uh like this but uh you you
got venmo cash app zell
word word um
and yeah this is like a beautiful story
why don't you tell the cats after dark
fans if they're not familiar what
happened dude
um i was in a terrible car accident and
uh i had to relearn out how to do
everything pretty much and um
just had just had facial reconstructive
surgery and went back to work today was
my first day back to work
that's great uh and you already won 100
so it's a good day i want to show a
picture of him from before so people can
really see what we're talking about
because it looks so much better man good
for you amazing probably a couple more
surgeries
uh
i have one more of my nose coming in
about five weeks and then uh cornea
surgery on my eye within a maybe three
months or so wow wow well good luck man
you're looking for this hundred dollars
go get yourself a steak dinner with just
a hundred dollars i know
all right i we will put a picture of
post from uh the first time he zoomed in
on uh regular king of the sting um but
uh yeah so next game the real king in
this day i i this is my least favorite
so let's you want to hold our breasts
and first person to let go
i think someone should hold the other
person's nose so you know you're not
you're not cheating yeah it's nice you
could still cheat yeah yeah just just be
honest we're gonna hold our nose fine
you ready chin can't help but cheat
it's part of his nature yeah it's in the
korean
hard workers man
all right i'm just worried about other
people cheating that's why i brought it
up
this will be the first shooter uh but um
okay
i'm just timing it because i'm curious
eric you gotta do this too
uh i'll go one two three go
some big preparation here
two
three
go
the thing is i feel like we shouldn't
all be doing this because then it's just
going to be a lot of dead air
i'll do it and i'll shoot
nick
no you want us to keep no we need those
for target practice god i just can't
imagine how good it feels to breathe you
know
so i feel like
they're 20 seconds in right now
i don't know i could go only go like
40 seconds have you tried holding your
breath like underwater recently that's
just a lot harder than i remember i
haven't been yeah it's always hard no
one likes to not breathe like it sucks
that's true actually i mean unless you
like unless you're into like autoerotic
asphyxiation i mean i think that's just
you
it is i don't even know what that means
eric's struggling
in that movie
he wants to talk about
i know right when we said auto erratic
appreciation eric started peeking up
he's like i have something to say about
this
shane's not even struggling so i feel
like are you serious
oh i think i could go longer
and i put my nose next to this so people
know i'm not cheating
the text is
[Laughter]
and i put it right next to it
no that's exactly you guys can't see i'm
an audio engineer i know if you're an
audience you can hear if anything comes
out oh my god you sound like oh you
don't we don't know that koreans
actually
breathe that only he could solve
this is a weird hole that comes out i
heard korean
i was impressed because that was like me
really trying i was like i'll die
but then you're also
[Laughter]
you're barely yourself right now though
you're only half of yourself i'm
sweating you're a lung supply and nick
passes out you have halfway alongside
the table i know you're just
[ __ ]
dude i could have went on for a decent
amount well i've lost myself 200 dollars
i got to start winning my money back no
you've well eric has 100 bucks so that's
not losing yeah all right so do you want
to do target practice or do you want to
do trivia now uh
target practice trivia and what was the
water water oh yeah and operations
yeah he can win he could have won six
hundred dollars he can win 400 more
dollars okay uh and uh chin and i will
go out because we're going to have 90
seconds he'll ask six questions and
instead of like writing them down we'll
go out so we don't hear them one of us
will come back we'll do it oh gotta go
got you eric first can you time i get to
stay then yeah yeah yeah
making the guess knock it out i planned
it uh but yeah 90 seconds on the clock
uh christian will read the thing
christian or chin and i will go outside
90 seconds yeah counting or going down
do you want me to tell you you can just
do timer okay do you want me to say the
category hey siri set timer for 90
seconds yeah i got it i go thank you
no
so let's just lie and say eric want them
all and then
quickly
no i'm not letting her get off this easy
lock the door
all right come on correct this for me i
got no i'm gonna i'm gonna go let me
know when to start
no i'm gonna feel important i'm gonna
sit over here now oh my god
i to look you in your eyes while you're
answering these questions all right
let's go
all right
so
the first question is going to be huh
first question is going to be history
which feisty u.s governor was
caricatured as a being able to see
russia from her home uh sarah palin
yep correct
all right this is an entertainment in
jurassic park what where did the
dinosaur dna come from uh
frogs
oh really mosquitoes preserved in amber
oh but they they use the frog dna
to mix in combine them that's actually
you should get double points yeah you're
handling that yeah so consensus all
right yeah fine
geography what is a german highway
system called the audubon yeah
uh sports sports and leisure what's the
name of the vehicle used to resurface
the ice at a hockey arena
uh zambino san benito close enough
45 seconds which part of the skeletal
structure of the human head is unique
and is not shared with any other species
on earth
uh
[Music]
the cranium
close close
uh but no it's the chin the chin oh wow
interesting right yeah is that it arts
and literature and which play did larry
david make his broadway debut as both an
actor and a playwright oof i have no
idea
fish in the dark okay i would never have
known that
and that's it so you were what four for
six yep yeah
all right
with 17 seconds to spare yeah
looking good for you eric looking good
for you
[Laughter]
you hear the ferrari pull up yeah
[Laughter]
how did your bmi surgery go eric
uh when well i just weighed in at the
doctor's not too long ago and i'm down
201 pounds hey that's [ __ ] amazing
brother oh nick hell yeah
i was watching the uh
where it burned back
to help you get that surgery man that's
exciting i know i'm very excited
all right uh how much uh
eric four out of six don't tell him okay
you shouldn't tell him oh wow now he has
the pressure now he's gonna be like i
gotta get
okay
six i'm like oh that impressive eric but
then i'm like did they pick two easier
questions because they told them fine
it's kind of hard
so you're insulting me no no well i've
honestly one of the questions i picked i
figured eric was be the only one to know
the answer to kind of fried chicken
[Laughter]
all right nicholas are you ready yes
all right three two one history which
feisty u.s governor was caricatured as
being able to see russia from her home
uh palin okay ding ding ding
in jurassic park where did the dinosaur
dna come from
uh uh mosquitoes and amber
okay
[ __ ] all right what is the uh german
highway system called
autobahn
sports and leisure what is the name of
the vehicle used to resurface the ice at
a hockey game uh zamboni of course he
would know that
why is that eric minnesota
science which part of the skeletal
structure of the human head is unique
and is not shared with any other species
on earth
[ __ ] the nose the chin
damn you got that that's crazy i didn't
get it oh why aren't in literature in
which play did larry david make his
broadway debut as both an actor and his
playwright
curb your enthusiasm on broadway
we got all the same ones uh yeah i
honestly thought eric would be the only
one to get the sarah palin one i don't
know why
yeah and i thought eric would get the
sarah palin one and the arts and
literature one though those two i
thought i don't know larry david like
that
chin better get the head of that you're
gonna have to find unless chin wins
you're gonna have to find like a a
couple of extra
yeah tie breakers so while we do that
while i do that can you oh of course i
can we're not gonna say how many gallons
but we will tell you eric and i are tied
in north carolina
in three
two one history which feisty u.s
governor has was caricatured as being
able to see russia from her home
oh my gosh that damn girl sarah pauline
okay
jurassic park where did the dinosaur dna
come from
a mosquito
okay okay
geography
what is the german highway system called
das biat
no
the confidence yeah i was like
what is it
what is the name of the vehicle used to
resurface ice at a hockey game
a resurfacer
science which part of the
skeletal structure of the human head is
unique and is not shared with any other
species on earth the frontal lobe
no
it's actually the chin
that would suck if it is i think it is
in which play did larry david make his
broadway debut as both an actor and a
playwright
which play yeah
oh man it's not it's not curve your
enthusiasm on broadway cannot pass it's
kirby that's it you're already lost oh
all right how much more time do i have
uh 20 seconds it's not enough 90 seconds
is enough for six questions uh we both
got four you got three not even two two
damn quickly can we know kind of the
answer technically one and a half
no the mosquitos
that's kind of serious
it is an autobahn autobahn
and zamboni sarah palin
and these other two no one would know no
one is just so embarrassing
i know
sarah palin won because you guys you
should know that one i know you should
know all everything about
that that shin one is one like some of
these like oh like
i don't know you
you've heard the answer before it
sometimes you just never i've never
heard that about the chin honestly i
only that's because one of those little
facts that now you're gonna be sharing
that i know oh yeah so thank you guys
for that bringing up on the next game
all right
uh now we try to shoot these off well we
have to give a tiebreaker
oh yeah i forgot for you and ours yeah
you read it and whoever says it first or
or is there any type of like number so
it's like furthest or closest to the
number uh
or okay fine first one i like trivia
first to yeah yeah
okay
this is a sports question
which school won both the men's and
women nc double a basketball
championship education damn it that's
right
wow eric won yeah yeah
yeah
another hundred because it's like the
only women's basketball program
does it say the year 2003
no that is not one i think it was a
mecca okafor and diana taurasi
both the men's and women one was 94 in
2014. oh it didn't have to be the same
year got you got you um all right eric
another 200.
i don't know why i gave that to you
uh where's our hundreds there's eric's
money all right
target practice okay this one's fun
christian if you want to stand in the
middle of that that section and put the
cup up the the middle of that section
like where just kind of in the in the
center there
yes
can we do it from our seats yep and uh
if you could could you film with your
phone right there
and it comes back up you're good now i
think oh
he's got
are you [ __ ] sitting here i'm scared
there you go he's got a gun
oh it's off a little bit okay i got it
you can't move christian
oh
dude you stuck it into the wall
hey
oh
[Laughter]
and to bend a bent one it'll really oh
yeah
that's unfair
you were closer than both of us though
yeah but this angle
he has to shoot the air conditioning the
winds like how chin is competitive
competitive enough for today but not for
the last however many weeks of weight
loss this is much more uh like immediate
feedback
i want my fast stuff yeah uh instant
gratification
that is what i was looking for uh can i
get another bullet
oh
it fell off the front of the desk
thank you i'm good i'm good oh that was
a crooked bullet though put the cup on
your head
i'll give him that one yeah i know dude
you have to say some badass one-liner
before you know
i'm frustrated with myself that was
inappropriate i have to take extreme
ownership
payback for not getting the audio right
hey stop tilting down christian i'm
[ __ ] scared i don't want to get hit
it's a point
damn thing
oh i'm going to win this no
oh my god
christian you've seen me do this before
right yeah you did do it sorry since the
next john wilkes booth
john was smooth is like right next to
him
john wick's booth
it's pretty good fun guys that's pretty
good
[Laughter]
he comes here
he doesn't talk much he just lost his
dog
all right
i was never in a gang just so you know
you're holding it sideways though yeah
why are you yeah yeah no
that's it to show you i was never in the
game
that's going right there
yeah look at you all your confidence
just went away with that shot oh
the distance they're too
nice
oh my god don't tell it anymore
idiot it is he has the distance yeah the
distance is hard and they're all and
it's different each one each bullet
yeah that's very true
oh
i think we give it to eric because he
hit christian in the face
[Music]
uh so that's a hundred dollars there
three hundred dollars
he's gonna go splurge at wendy's like
all right i want chocolate frosties for
everybody they should be a target
christian we get to sit in john wick's
booth after thanksgiving all right so
this one operation i don't even know i
don't even think i've actually
seen it
i don't actually think i've ever played
operation you just have to pull it out
without yeah so without
oh so red is okay it's like warning yeah
okay
so should we do as many as you can get
in a row i think 60 seconds to see how
many you can get i like that but if you
buzz it then you have to pull it away
yeah or go for a different one no no
just just keep going just don't make it
vibrate okay but but we're starting
buzzing we're saying 60 seconds so you
can't just buzz and then i'm going to
keep going because it's supposed to be
oh that one's you're done with it oh
okay you can't go in that hole anymore
yeah yeah okay i like it
yeah
i thought you lose as soon as you butt
is if it vibrates that's that's normally
what happens but like we're trying to
get the game yeah okay okay for the sake
of all right so one minute
oh wow
if you want to be weird you don't even
have them in the right
it's hard to drop them in derek hey no
you've
and there's bones missing too where
are we started no
you ready start now
60 seconds
oh good job guys wow the hands of a
surgeon are you just humming the
two songs yeah
this is how i imagine it we're gonna
play the oh you mean
[Music]
no we're all thinking different things i
think you're thinking for me
no i'm thinking 30 seconds
oh huh
emmy nominations i know i mean it was
not a well-acted show what are we at i
mean it's hard to tell because you're
not crazy 15 seconds
but i mean it's true though there's just
different mannerisms different
expressions seven
six
five
four
three
two
one
and don't move these other ones because
they are like
i actually don't want to drop them back
in yeah eric do it yeah definitely you
put them in different is this in bad
case for sabotage i'm eric because all
the surgeries that's what she always
says
that's
this pete funny steve
yeah this is eric right here yeah
i'm just saying i'm pissed off if zoom
eric's doctor makes his nose glow red
just tell me when to go uh you ready uh
george yep
christian christian my phone just died
so make sure you record all of this
this is the job chin's parents wish he
had
but this is how chen eats
[Laughter]
i thought you guys dinner supposed to be
good at this channel
i need two hands
two fingers so this reminds me when are
we going to korean barbecue again
20 seconds
i'm out of bones
15 seconds
get the femur oh my god
yeah
wow you got four got four wow
so i beat erika i'm sorry eric what i
didn't get four you guys you got three
i didn't want to be there you want to
drop them in there
i see the
third center
slo-mo
eric we don't have that capability
the butterfly was hard and i actually
got the butterfly yeah
i should have went for that one
as a kid i always wanted this game it
seemed cool and this sucks i'm not yeah
i don't like that
okay i made it
let me make sure i have all of these
and then you say uh go when you're ready
to record and george will start the
timer
the silence of an operating ready three
two one go
58 seconds
that was fine
i never want nick to be my doctor i know
dude
yeah adderall doesn't help with surgery
or orthodontist
i'm watching the game
over under i get
[Music]
that was an angry one
you're an angry little ten seconds i
think i i buzzed myself out
i got three as well okay all right chin
wins
not bad i'm i've lost all my money
this is like a fight night
[Laughter]
nick's picks
we got one more challenge and it is fast
drinking water we're gonna need your
someone to record this again um
so you get a straw this is going to suck
eric and you it's not going to suck it's
like 30 seconds but someone will hold
the button and you just suck and once it
starts to overflow that's your time and
the long you have to you have to
so that's how i get into the podcast
world
you'll feel something in your mouth yeah
suck until you feel something down your
throat so who's reporting this sound
like nick's sex education
from your school
wait so someone has to record and
someone has to film uh press the button
for you yes
so can you record george
you want me the time uh
yes
[Music]
all right i think we're gonna need
everyone up then
on paper
yeah
who came up with this stupid idea
the guy who came up with the rest of the
stupid ideas
okay
should i give him hot water
is there room temp water there no it's
only cold water i think it's just coming
down
three
two one
this can last for a long time
he's too good at this
where you got
all right should we be start
it's where you gotta go
how's this broken yeah
it's not broken okay it's not broke oh
my gosh
well you can't keep the time going
because did you pause it longer
yeah yeah okay um
should we restart yeah or just remember
how many seconds that was
it's hard it's hard okay we'll just go
all right ready yeah three
two
1
the next girl is sucking he's so good at
sucking
dude and he's also even better at
swallowing yeah
it's about to go it is
oh it's millimeters away now if you're
doing this california drought i know
is it a fly yet or not oh yeah it did
34 seconds
it's actually a lot of water yeah
just made the 34-79 point
[Laughter]
nick can you weigh in now and see what
you weigh
he's got that water weight
do you want to do this eric
well it doesn't matter if you want to do
it or not you're doing it who says i
mean you can you can forfeit 100 easy
but i think eric here i mean he's
obligated for our fans
just needs to get a win
nick just needs some h2o in his brain
right
all right 3479
i'm sorry you can't see it eric it'll
it'll be i know you're watching on the
show it'll be cool all right 34 7.
count me down
whenever you're ready
come on over here this is it all right
going in there we go three two one
dude he's fast
oh look at that suck down i know it's
not even moving oh
but you get full
but you get full
this is amazing
this is everything i dreamed of
thank you so much eric griffin
don't make him laugh i'm trying i want
him to come out his nose two more
seconds
you officially beat nick dammit and he's
still not even oh now he's trying to get
highway there nope one back down
jesus oh my god there's no one's beating
eric
jesus
eric 400 dollars it looks like in your
pocket
one minute
oh my god okay
[Laughter]
that
and hydration is important so you did
good for your body too
a minute oh my god that's awesome i lost
all my money oh dude so how do we give
eric uh
you keep those two hundred dollars i
take these and i'm going to venture
so i'm going to use this for some sort
of charity then you at least need to
drink water like in general
you could
yeah yeah you're not going to try you
could just there's no way i'm going to
beat her
i think the way the ends this way is
even better because eric just destroyed
with the mic drop of him
all right
and uh you you said you might give it a
charity we could just give the whole 600
yeah me and eric me and eric have a
me and eric have a little bond here
right yeah we're good how are you
feeling
you got it bro hydrated yeah
uh and we're we'll wrap it up extremely
healthy
i feel hydrated
i'm feeling good after that
i've been drinking water my whole life
everything led up to this moment
all the water i never drove my life led
up to this championship time i'd like to
thank god for turning my delicious water
into wine
we're doing this and the people in
jackson mississippi i know they're like
michigan
they don't have drinking water for like
indefinitely they're like having to bust
it in i don't [ __ ] know did michigan
their water thing or not i don't think
so no one's talking about it
but uh yeah so yeah we're just cocking
off about all our water in california
with the drought with our water it was
for a good cause eric
use it use this money and uh do whatever
you want inspirational keep us posted
man like you got to come back again yeah
so we can see after the other surgeries
i appreciate it guys thank you very much
it means a lot to even zoom in with you
guys yeah and i sent a picture to the
other guys to the uh you know to the
crew and everybody's sending good wishes
to you man yeah man
replied oh you can't even tell
oh and uh i meant to say you guys were
asking about pain medication eric i only
take tylenol oh good for you ever since
you'll be able to afford a lot more now
no pain meds at all nice that's great
man good for you man that can't be easy
either way to cut it out
yeah you're the man one of our favorite
listeners dude thank you thank you very
much guys i really appreciate it all
right well take it easy dude
uh this is my one of my favorite
episodes we've ever done have a go and
eric yeah all right see you guys see ya
so uh we go out anything to a plug eric
see that's like so we i hate that about
zoom actually by the way real quick it's
like you go all right bye and then
there's this whole like
five seconds of end meeting leave
meetings and then the people still on
screen just like looking at you like i
already say goodbye yeah [ __ ]
i'm saying goodbye i'm gonna say goodbye
until i set up yeah yeah it should be
like a quick button press yeah
i agree with that uh but my plugs eric
griffin.com i got some dates coming up
i'm going to be in la jolla i'm going to
be in milwaukee i'm going to be at the
skankfest in las vegas shout out uh um
louis gomez
and uh i'm gonna be in um
colusa casino
i just realized we didn't talk about uh
your white mic yeah yeah but we can we
can save that for next time
you guys just got to finish all your
news so you can be in here yeah
but uh
uh anything plug uh you guys can follow
me on instagram nick will put the
description to bio i am opening for
chappelle lacey in irvine on september
8th [ __ ] yeah yeah that is awesome and i
have uh derwolf in pasadena on
thursday but i guess actually this will
come out friday so yeah uh george
uh my instagram at door terrace 48
there's also a new youtube for the 12
pack oh yeah 12 packs so follow the
brand new youtube channel 12 packs with
jeff dye we open cards and drink it's
fun oh i was going to tell you guys if
you want like make like a 30 second or
minute commercial and we'll just put it
in the middle okay that's really cool um
christian uh
on instagram see payload six um check
out the podcast i work with called you
already know with keenan thompson and
tammy monroe uh and then we just
officially officially dropped the merch
it's now available to buy we have like
already 15 orders in in a day so
please show your love and get some merch
oh yeah
so i got a few things first of all eric
thank you so much for wearing my collab
shirt with into the a.m
we worked really hard on that so yeah
thank you so much for that and that you
can get that at into the am dot com
slash chin dash no sorry yeah into the
am dot com slash chin dash t we'll have
the link down there jesus
hey man i know
[Laughter]
and then um uh just chinsuyi on my
instagram youtube everything but another
thing i got a new piece of work from
johnny ocean at um
mojave creative in santa monica if you
want really great tattoos he's he's a
badass all right
too dope if you want to make sure okay
yeah
i want to make this make any bad choices
he's
another podcast show check that out
that's my other show i do one of my
favorite things i do all week and that's
it all right nice thanks guys
[Music]
[Music]
you